le sedici artisti siamo ritornati su uno
è veramente un gioco incredibile ma
l'ultima volta ho vinto anche abbastanza
questa qua
vedremo sempre col gatto ciccio e pietro
lescot o solo con ciccio dai va bene ah
no ma io non dietro solo con pietro no
va bene ma deve fare li facciamo dai cui
si arrende non vinceremo mai noi due ma
dall 8 in pietro allora questa poltrona
del mondo ecco bravo già stiamo perdendo
visto lavoro normale gioco con uno che
non gioca ragazzi questo è un valore
la colpa mia centro di roma è normale ma
è normale la male normale
ok si e allora ecco quel 7 grazie sicura
ma porca paletta non ci credo
no non cambi sono una mamma poteva
giocarsela peccato amato pesca e quanto
pesca pittoriche di bile pazzeschi raga
pazzesco che gran partita non avrei mai
detto ragazzi demolito di mi piace sto
video va bene ma no ma io ho sbagliato a
premere ancora da ieri
[Musica]
che schifo di carico massimo ma
ritorniamo ritorniamo così un po
fastidio e ad rom hanno visto negato a
robinho molto bella molto carina no no
sta valutando eh lo so io lo conosco
troppo bene questione è lì che scemo va
beh non è un problema mi è parso è pazzo
pensavo facesse molto di peggio invece
ed ecco il numero uno ed ecco di cosa
per vabbè
mi piace particolarmente il russo non è
vero ma controllino contesti la cosa con
di sfida ma non dice la fine pesco 26
poi ok ok 10 carte grafiche blu ho
scelto l'altra non ha ricordi ce n'era
un'altra tutto strana mi ricordo tutto è
strana chi ha già un blu è entrato anche
ottima shook me all your era un blu o
devo cambiare in verde ma va benissimo
[Musica]
ma la nonna dice facciamo però il gioco
ha detto dopo l'ha detto allora questo
cambio colore basta la basta oddio pone
attenzione alla fine dai alla fine
percezione grandissimo ma era ovvio no
no no no no pescale pure tutte cento
pardi comincia ho sbagliato ho sbagliato
la squadra ma non importa dai facciamo
colore che paletta porca paletti si ma
no è vero questa funziona finzione ma
basta ma valuta prendi questo pezzo di
me io non so dire no vuol dire che ce lo
sfido ma non era per cui per lui al
verde aveva bello pescate in un pescato
un milione perché volevo metterla al
cappuccino non può rapportarsi a lui
quando la bella la bella dai che oggi
pietro la vinte due non posso chiedere
video così ma ancora con ciccio ma basta
le carte che dopo un ultimo dato è certo
un lotto ok anch'io lotto ma come se non
riusciamo mai è sempre la stessa base
salti ma io lo sapevo
5 direi ma direi che il 5
che brutta scelta questo dato quello che
a ok non è vero io esisto molto cattivo
o no lo sapevi io lo sapevo ancora già
prima di chi facesse la mer di lor ma
solo un contesto ma la cosa è stata sei
un pezzente ti conosco
bravissimi lancia le rosse ma siamo
sicuri controlliamo
però però ce l'hai ma che tu lo hai ma
grazie ma prego cerca di importante non
mi interessa
questo video assunto un piacere che
prima va bene hanno accoltellato questo
credito ma che fanno bravo bravo adesso
con lo scià tutti i più 4 c invece no e
io dico rosso non vengono corso tra
tanti colori quello che non sa chi ci
guarda 12 che ha detto uno l'ha detto e
ho detto l'ho ribadito che è caduto cosa
contesta no no no saggia scelta e non so
se però funziona quello che voglio fare
proprio un testo con te io contro il
governo
bravo così funziona ma come si sia corte
di invece una ragione poi qualcosa
prendiamo la plage che non ho capito
questo ma con la galera ci lasci fare la
cima aveva giochiamo per chi scrive
[Applauso]
mammamia bravo io non ho capito questo è
successo col più 4 ma perché ho pescato
io perché poi li giocare altri 4 altre
carte possono effettuare che è giusto
che ci sono scemo ai ciccio questa la
vinciamo a questa me la sento ora pista
e io che lo ribadisco sa ma vado bravo
ma di quei pesca anche io non c'ero io
ma bravo bravo ragazzi così in punkow
era ancora notte
ora basta ora basta
che miseria mas chiamato non è proprio
diverbi e allora niente skiff esistito
chiamando si chiama io l'avevo
riflettere ma e le vuole pescare una blu
ah beh le pesco il nome bro
si no nos peschi e quindi devo una prova
con la dovendo sempre dietro almeno una
stazione arrivano 16 cielo come
l'aspettavo 11 provino 17 tranquillo 17
carte si fa male pure a dirlo 17 sa bene
che noi e io andrei sul blu bravo e vice
del cherubino acerbi e piacersi un bel
color da york dove ma basta allora fammi
vedere quanti vertice io invece è il
diario di una giunta di potere una
giunta e cambierei colore aia solo
perché mi fido ciecamente del signor
gatto non contestare problema di un
rally
mara che quest'uomo non ha le palle
vediamo seminati blu adesso l'approccio
alle palle da mamma mia attenzione
attenzione non so se contestare perché
la punta del gruppo è arrabbiata pazzo
ha proprio quella e io tornei sul rosso
no però sono sono neanche sempre più
verde al giallo
io titolo d'esempio l'atmosfera per
tornare una donna ma ce l'hai dio che fa
cup tra poco al mazzo finisce come
funziona sembra che sia infinito il
mazzo non lo so un blu mi piaceva
particolarmente ma invece più giallo ma
come a uno quello di tc prato dai topi
topi e ciccio non è mio ma siamo a venti
e verde quella di piede mi sa che hanno
vinto non posso farli nulla
signore e signori parabola campione nel
mondo incredibile è durata un'ora
ragazzi tre vittorie di pietro possiamo
chiudere il mondo io un po l'odio quel
luogo però fa niente meno che vi sia
piaciuto a me è un po meno però è stato
molto divertente comunque lo stesso
perché anche perdere a 1 con gli amici
porca vacca è comunque bello mi scrivete
a creare servizi di schiacciate mi piace
è rilasciato un commento e noi ci
vediamo come sempre ma la ragazza
[Musica]